hello my name is Claire Foy and these
are my favorite films one of my favorite
films is rear window by Alfred Hitchcock
if I could live in any movie I'd like to
live in rear window just without the
murder element I can't remember how old
I was when I first watched it I think I
was quite young and I just wanted to
live in that apartment and look out the
window and see all those people I wanted
to see the ballerina in the apartment
across and I wanted to hear the music
and the couple who have that dog and
they lower the dog down in the basket
and the thriller side of it and the kind
of murder and that thing wasn't quite as
important as just sort of the the
feeling of it and the feeling also have
understanding that Grace Kelly and James
Stewart were in this apartment together
and that was sort of a little bit
illicit at that period of time and he
was a photographer and she was a you
know an it girl and it just she her
clothes were amazing
when I Met Sally because it's just the
gift that keeps on giving really I mean
you can't ever not watch it and be
charmed by it I think it's such a
charming film
I had an absolute fascination with meg
Ryan when I was younger and it's really
interesting watching as an adult because
I watched it so much as a kid and then
watching as an adult and the way that
they talked about relationships and
Billy Crystal kind of saying men and
women can't be friends just very
interesting now then you grow up and you
kind of think about the ideas behind the
film but I just think it's so charming
and it's just a classic snaps new
classic Bridges of Madison County I
don't feel like I've got to explain why
because it's just Meryl Streep so much
about it is heartbreaking you know I
can't film what to cry I just every
single time and it's the bit where she's
in the in the petrol station when she's
got a hand on that door to get out and
they go to the traffic lights and you
can see she's thinking oh god oh god oh
god oh god in her heart she's breaking
her heart she's breaking and then her
husband dies and then she tries to find
him and she can't find him and then she
gets the thing then a medal of Robert
Kincade it's just oh it's just the best
film ever
Thirteenth which I just thought was
amazing and I just think a you know
documentaries have the power to kind of
highlight really important social issues
and are able to completely completely
change the way you live your life I'm
more inspired as an actor weirdly by
documentary than anything but I just
mean it was a beautifully crafted
documentary and I think it
it achieved exactly what she must have
set out to achieve unfaithful as one of
my favorite films to me it signifies a
period of time when a film could didn't
have to fit into a genre it didn't have
to be one thing to be successful it's
amazing I think it's a really erotic
film I think it's got it's one of those
films that you watch it and you feel
like you've got a heavy stone on your
chest when you're watching it you know
that the filmmaker is telling you that
something's not quite right you don't
know why that is or what it is I think
Diane Lane is amazing in it I think it's
amazing performance for her and I just
love it I just love it I love a film
about a middle-aged woman in America and
I just love it I just love it I love the
pace of it I love it